virtual reality is often associated with
video games but well-known companies are
now using it as a tool to train for
potentially dangerous situations
the popular technology immerses users in
a digital world
so major companies like Walmart Chipotle
and Verizon are using VR to prepare
employees for what they could see on the
job
Toni de copal experienced some of the
training himself and he's at a Verizon
store right here in New York City
Toni good morning to you good morning
good morning here's a location you may
recognize Verizon has more than 1,600
stores like this one all across the
country there are places where frontline
employees help people get connected and
of course sell the gizmos and the
gadgets to do so but that can create a
problem it's a reality of retail that
hot ticket items like this can be a
magnet for armed robbery a dangerous
scenario that can be difficult or even
impossible to imagine or was until now
two gunmen strike as the store opens
take me to the epitome taking one
employee hostage let's go and going
straight for the safe it was only a
simulation but as we learn firsthand at
this Verizon training site outside
Washington DC the fear was all too real
Virtual Reality takes your brain
elsewhere so I'm standing here in a
classroom and my brain thinks I'm on a
factory floor on an airplane tarmac in a
Verizon store so it's basically like
visualization on steroids
Derrick belch is the founder of Stryver
which builds virtual experiences as a
training tool first for football teams
now for a growing number of major
companies Walmart's program lets sales
associates feel the holiday rush
JetBlue technicians can inspect an
airplane before takeoff and this year
Verizon plans to send 15,000 frontline
workers through a program aimed to put
everyone at the wrong end of a gun when
people come to work for a Verizon I
imagine the potential for armed
robberies not something they're
considering so why remind them about it
well because it's a real
it's a reality we can't ignore it
Michael Mason is chief security officer
at Verizon he says that while Verizon
sees fewer than 50 armed robberies a
year just one is enough to make the
training worth it I wouldn't call it a
minor problem anytime you get a gun
stuck in your face you get a knife stuck
in your face that's a serious problem do
you think this training has the
potential to save the life down the road
if nothing else then an employee
understands what he or she should be
looking at and the bad guy when they're
in and if that helps identify a bad guy
and take them off the street that means
they can't repeat that activity the
training features three virtual reality
experiences and armed robbery at store
opening and armed robbery at closing and
a smash-and-grab job during store hours
throughout the ordeal employees answer
questions about what to do in real time
I'm coming for you then discuss it as a
group how has your impression about
store security changed the first thought
to meet was the key columns of the
customers can stay home a Rouge Khalid
manages a Verizon store in Reston
Virginia it was emotional it was
traumatic in a lot of ways it was raw it
was like awakening of what more I could
be doing in my role to take that
education piece and what happens day to
day back to my team
Verizon security chief says the goal of
all this training isn't to protect the
inventory but in fact to protect the
people and I asked him why even talk
publicly about this training and he was
clear he said it's to send a message to
the bad guys if you come for the phones
if you come for the gadgets the people
in stores like this one are going to be
prepared Noora and that message is being
sent the good one Tony thank you so much